hi I'm Kevin Merida the Washington Post
and we're here with Michael long author
of first-class citizenship the civil
rights letters of Jackie Robinson here
in afterwards welcome Michael thank you
Kevin good deal with you tell us how
this book came about well in December of
2005 well I was conducting research on a
strange but true friendship between
Billy Graham and Richard Nixon and my
research had taken me to the National
Archives Laguna Niguel and while I was
there a great archivist Paul warm sir
approached the desk one afternoon and
asked me whether I had seen the Jackie
Robinson file it was a great question
and I hadn't seen the file and Paul
brought it back and for the next couple
hours I just poured through the
correspondence it was a huge stack of
correspondence between Robinson and
Nixon and I was hooked
I was hooked because this is the Jackie
Robinson that I just did on now and I
got really excited about the
correspondence I wasn't quite sure what
to do with it but then I went back to my
hotel room that night and I watched a
sports show about athletes gone bad and
so I decided to introduce the world to
this better role model of Jackie
Robinson and or to reintroduce the world
to a better role model in Jackie
Robinson and from there I went to Rachel
Robinson and as for her permission to
publish a collection of letters between
Nixon and Robinson and she graciously
agreed rachel has a long talented Jackie
Robinson as an informal civil rights
leader and so she was enthusiastic about
the project and from there I went to the
Library of Congress to look at the
Jackie Robinson papers and two other
archives across the country and I really
discovered that he wrote not only to
Nixon but the figures like like
Eisenhower and Malcolm X John Kennedy
and a rough Bunch
I Adam Clayton Powell and Barry
Goldwater and I thought to myself I
really need to include these letters too
and so I went back to Rachel Robinson
and she graciously agreed and then was
in the year I secured a first rank
literary agent then - Lowenthal the
david black agency in New York City and
she pitched the book to one of the best
Brooklyn Dodgers fan Holly olive of
times book and from there I worked with
my research associate Sharon her and we
published a book within a year and a
half and we published it in 2007 to mark
the 60th anniversary of Jackie
Robinson's role in shattering the color
barrier in Major League Baseball it's a
wonderful book and a wonderful
contribution to the understanding of
Jackie Robinson because you see him you
hear him in his own words and you can
kind of trace the trajectory of his life
in his public career that way just where
our viewers you wonder what what did the
letters look like for those who haven't
done research and presidential libraries
or done any kind of archival work they
just placed these boxes and where they
faded yellow letters what kind of paper
did he use yeah it's really exciting to
hold original documents and a lot of the
documents were letters that were on
stationery chock full o'Nuts stationery
in 1957 Jackie Robinson took a job as
vice president of personnel at chock
full o'Nuts in New York and he were a
lot of the civil rights letters on chalk
stationery and they're really expecting
stationery it's bright green chock full
o'Nuts and is written at the top and
then Jackie would writing letters on the
stationery but a lot of the letters were
faded brown ripped torn and the
telegrams were blue and yellow all of
them faded and it's just exciting to
hold those original documents in your
hands and to think Wow
check it Robinson wrote this letter some
of the letters as you note we'll go
through it and write how did you tell
which ones were and which ones weren't
it was pretty easy to track the rhetoric
and so William branch was a ghostwriter
for Jackie Robinson and Branch Road
Robinson's new york post call
and Alfred Duquette was a ghostwriter
for Robinson as well and bucket road
with great rhetorical flourish and you
can see an example of that in Robinson's
letters to Barry Goldwater so it's
pretty easy to track the rhetorical
flourishes
Evelyn Cunningham formerly the
Pittsburgh courier and then later an
employee of Nelson Rockefeller also
helped Robinson with the letters and
when you see somebody smile I think it's
pretty easy to track it even though
they're trying to put it in Jackie's
Jackie Robinson's words but I will say
that all of the ghostwriters are in the
documents by jackie robinson and it was
his voice coming through and it was his
sentiment coming through as well the
letters are uniquely Jackie Robinson
voice even though he had helped he had
some help crafting some of the letters
and a lot of the letters were written by
Jackie Robinson himself - they say you
received the permission from Rachel
Robinson his widow were there any
letters that she was concerned about or
wanted to be left out or did she express
any reservations and want to want to see
the letters before publication Rachel
Robinson was really good to work with
and and she didn't not pull any letters
from the project at all so in that sense
she was a complete gem there were
individuals however who didn't give
their permission for the letters to
appear in the book and there were
individuals who did not respond to my
repeated inquiries I'd love to tell you
who they are but you can't but I better
but what do you think we learn overall
about Robinson there wasn't known from
these letters that's a great question
here's what I think we've done I think
American pop culture has frozen Jackie
Robinson in 1947 and this of course was
the year he shattered the color barrier
and it was the year two that he was
turning the other cheek so then he would
face racist years and taunts and
slashing spikes he would just turn the
other cheek and it did that because
Branch Rickey the GM of the Brooklyn
Dodgers at the time had instructed him
to do so
Rickey was a an occasionally good
madness and always a shrewd tactician
and he knew that if Robinson fought back
in that first year it would be an
impossible experiment to complete until
he instructed him with the biblical
admonition turn the other cheek and
Robinson was a great soldier and he did
exactly that and I think that most
Americans especially white Americans
have frozen him in that period why have
we done that because he's
non-threatening he slides into the base
he takes the racist cheers he gets up he
brushes the dust off his uniform and
then he just plays on and we love that
and that type of Jackie Robinson also
entertains us and we frozen him there I
believe because he's so non-threatening
well the letters break that mold and so
a completely different type of Jackie
Robinson well speaking of that that
period when he broke the color barrier
in 1947 as you mentioned he received
many death threats you published one of
the letters you actually show it
photographically he received numerous
death threats and I'll just read a
couple of them you said one of those to
Jackie Robinson receives and we have
already got rid of several like you one
was found in river just recently
Robinson we're going to kill you if you
attempt to enter a ballgame across the
field sign the travelers and receive May
20th 1951 that's four years into his
tenure there was another one that
spelled out a very specific date for his
death September 15 1953 you'll be
executed gangland style at Busch Stadium
the letter said signed dodger hater
how did Rob
deal with those kind of threats I can't
imagine how he must have felt walking
out on the field thinking that there
were people in the stands who wanted to
kill him and it's a great testament to
his character to think that he went to
the field anyway and he spun homeruns in
the face of these would-be assassins
I think he'd go with a lot of his
friends by relying on his face Robinson
had a childhood hero in reverend carl
downs in california and robinson really
relied on it that childhood faith that
he developed with carl downs and he grew
he gained strength and courage from his
belief in god and then the quality of
people and he took that face and just
soldiered on us it's an amazing and
amazing event
you know Robinson had so many gifts that
I think that most people are unaware of
and of course a number of jobs you
mentioned a chock full of nuts one but I
was struck by early on one letter a
Branch Rickey had written to him just
three years after he ended baseball and
he said that he hoped that one day that
Robinson could be a manager on the field
and that he thought that more than any
other player in the game he was equipped
to be a manager that was a striking
thing to say at a time when there was no
sign of anybody possibly running a
ballclub what do you think that said
about how Rickey view Robinson skills
well it really recognized Branch Rickey
who recognized that Robinson had
incredible leadership skills and that he
did and Branch Rickey really was the
father that Jackie Robinson never had
and so I think in some ways it's also a
testament to Ricky's love for Jackie
Robinson and the two were very close
through the years not only during the
baseball units but in the post baseball
years as well are Jackie Robinson
eventually wrote an article titled why
can't I cook
major league baseball lucky I managed in
Major League Baseball
and he never did I think Robinson was
really attracted to business and
commerce opportunities following
baseball but that question still nag at
him and in 1972 he was invited to throw
out the ceremonial pitch of the World
Series and he really opted not to in the
beginning because he was so frustrated
that there were no African American
managers in baseball and and so Bowie
Kuhne came back to and said what if I
tell you that we're working on the
problem and I'll eventually have some
and Robinson I relented and really gave
in but when he threw out that pitch he
said I'm very proud to be here today but
I'll be a lot happier when I look at
that third-base line and I see a black
manager so a gun in his great day and
that's that's characteristically Jackie
Robinson well while he had a co-hosted a
sports show with a white broadcaster and
talked about hoping that it could go
national but was concerned that the
country wasn't ready for that and then
later wrote a column for the New York
Post first and he was eventually
dismissed from that job by the the
editor for essentially some of his
activities related to Richard Nixon I
want to ask you maybe that's a segue to
get into his relationship with Richard
Nixon but he was very closely connected
with Richard Nixon yes a few met in 1952
at the Republican National Convention
and they were introduced by a California
operative by the name of Harrison McCall
who actually wrote a memo on the meeting
in later years and when the two-minute
on Nixon who was a huge sports fan
especially a baseball fan I recounted to
play in 1939 that Robinson was involved
in in a game between UCLA and the
University of Oregon football teams and
Robinson was dazzled and he was quite
and fraud by Nixon's sport enthusiasm
and the two began a course
bonods they're lasted until 1972 I can
talk a little bit about why Jackie
Robinson was attracted to Nixon if you
like me - yeah I noted that sometimes
the letters would be with my dear mr.
Nixon right yes early on Robinson was a
huge fan of Nixon for several reasons
Nixon had been making pro-civil rights
statements in the early 1950s and that
was really unheard of for a politician
of his stature at that point especially
in his party and so when he would go
abroad and even when he was here in the
United States he would say things like
every time an act of discrimination
happens here in America it's as if were
handing a gun to the Communists and
Nixon would also talk about the problems
of delaying civil rights legislation in
1957 Nixon toured Africa he pushed for
civil rights legislation and in Robinson
was taken by all that so when 1960 came
around he back to Nixon over Kennedy
pretty easily I'll go to Kennedy if
that's okay and yet he did a Segway on
the Kennedy yeah Robinson was no fan of
John F Kennedy in 1960 at all and for a
couple reasons he felt that Kennedy had
been absolutely wrong when he voted to
send the 1957 civil rights legislation
back to committee and a southern
engineered attempt to kill the
legislation and I really ticked off
Robinson quite a bit I Robinson was also
disturbed that Kennedy had private
meetings with southern segregationists
especially governor of Alabama
John Patterson Tory and and Robinson
when he wrote about that would fit I
wonder why
Kennedy is the fair-haired son of Dixie
and he would get into these digs he put
these digs in his column quite a bit
he was also disturbed when he met
Kennedy and Georgetown in the meeting in
a private meeting arranged by former
Connecticut governor check bolds Mike
Kennedy was courting Robinson in the
1960 campaign they had a private meeting
and Robinson says Nixon
and never looked me in the unfair excuse
me Kennedy never looked me in the eye
even once and then not only that he also
told me that he just didn't know a whole
lot about the african-american folks and
about their concerns and so these
reasons really suck Kennedy off plus
Kennedy chooses LBJ as his running mate
and Robinson sees him as quote a proven
segregationist and so he steers towards
Nixon and eventually backed him the 1960
campaign for which he took a lot of heat
yes and that you know is the kind of
thing that many African Americans take
now which is know an irony because back
then there were more African Americans
supporting Republican Party and that's
certainly drifted now and you know
african-americans give like 90 percent
of their vote the Democrats back then it
was a lot more of a contested situation
and it seemed that Robinson was one
urging a a two-party system right yes
Robinson's politics consistently steer
Republican force in the Republican Party
plans towards freedom it's the party of
Abraham Lincoln it's the party of
racially progressive politicians like
Nelson Rockefeller and you're dramedy
and Rumson spheres that way he also
believes in what you what you just call
the two-party system II think he thinks
it's problematic if glass will give all
their votes to the Democratic Party and
his major dream as major political dream
of this two-party system that's a party
it's a system I'm sorry in which
Democrats and Republicans will heavily
cord the african-american vote and in
which African Americans will really vote
for whichever candidate and whichever
party will best serve their interests
that's rumsen's huge political dream the
two-party system another thing on
Kennedy just were
moment this is what he wrote to Richard
Nixon after Kennedy had been elected I
hope I am wrong in my appraisal of
president-elect Kennedy but cannot help
but feel our country is the loser not
you this was he wrote to Richard Nixon
was he wrong about the Kennedys
ultimately they had some in letters that
went back and forth between both Bobby
Kennedy and John Kennedy and Robinson
and they were trying to convince him
that you know I think Kennedy at one
point said you know I had a breakfast
meeting with the governor but I'm not in
you know sync with segregations and the
seem that Robinson just didn't quite
believe it right let me back up a little
bit and talk about the end of the 1960
election and then I'll get into that
question a Robinson was disappointed at
the end of the 1960 election not only
because Kennedy won but especially
because he felt that the Nixon campaign
team intentionally ignored African
American areas like Harlem he was also
disappointed with Richard Nixon Robinson
approached Nixon at the end of campaign
right around October I should say and
asked Nixon to contact Martin Luther
King it was just beginning to serve time
in a Regional State Prison in Georgia
and Nixon declined saying that the call
would be grandstanding and this
infuriates Robinson he is thinking about
quitting the campaign and he comes out
of the meeting
let's tears welling in his eyes he felt
so passionate about it well in the
meantime JFK made a call to Coretta
Robert Kennedy secured King's release
and we know where the african-american
vote went and we know who won the
election and so Robinson at the end of
the campaign is still pretty upset about
that and he sends a letter to the RNC
chair about it and he says we really
need to work on building this two-party
system and the RNC chair at the time
Albert Herman writes back and says he
really could be a messiah for the
Republican Party well it doesn't happen
and after that Kennedy warms up a little
bit to Kennedy especially at the
beginning of
Kennedy's years in the White House
Kennedy makes them ever Jers toward the
african-american voters some more he has
Louis Martin formerly the Chicago
Defender to go to the DNC he appoints
Harris Wofford to run the Civil Rights
Division in the White House and that was
a pollution that hadn't been filled for
some time and so there's some real
positive things going on in the
beginning of Kennedy's years but
Robinson sours on Kennedy he sours on
Kennedy doing Freedom Riders when he
believes that Kennedy really did not
send in troops as quickly as he could
have he sound was on Kennedy during the
Albany campaign when he believes that
Kennedy should have sent troops he sours
on Kennedy during the Birmingham
campaign when it believes that Kennedy
should have sent troops and a lot faster
and so he has lots of problems with
Kennedy but in June 1 June 11 1963
Kennedy gives his great civil rights
speech and Robinson watches it with
Rachel and they're absolutely enthralled
with Kennedy and Robinson later writes
in his column after that speech I agree
with my wife who said mr. Kennedy just
won re-election so he does come to
Kennedy side but he later criticizes him
yet again so he goes back and forth like
I just have a great friend it's a
hallmark of kind of Robinson's politics
I mean he supported human free and
criticized Barry Goldwater in 64 they
called him a bigot and a menace to the
country which Goldwater was not too
thrilled with that and you include a
letter in which Goldwater responds to
Robinson saying that you have attacked
me rather viciously on several occasions
without ever having done me the courtesy
to call and say let's sit down and see
just where you stand on these various
issues yes
Coldwater put out this letter of
invitation now why is he writing to
Robinson well we have to remember that
Robinson had the virtual star power of
poker he wasn't quite like but he could
attract huge multiracial crowds
and at one point Goldwater says I'm not
just writing you because you're somebody
whose opinion counts and it was exactly
right Robinson was a national icon an
American icon and people listened to him
and so he writes to Robinson requesting
a meeting and Robinson fires back a
blistering reply so what good is a
meeting going to do with you are you
going to tell me that you desegregated
the National Guard in Arizona are you
going to tell me why you voted against
the civil rights legislation are you
going to tell me why you support states
rights are you going to tell me why you
form alliances while you seem to pour
alliances with Ku Klux Klan and the John
Birchers look mr. Goldwater reasons
you've called for extremism and it's
coming back to you and Molotov cocktails
what about that and Goldwater doesn't
reply you know it's you think about
where Robinson was politically in
different places where do you think he
would be today who would he be
supporting in this presidential campaign
well it's a great question and somewhere
he's impossible I think with his
pro-business right stance he would steer
a bit towards Romney but I think that he
would definitely come down with Obama
only because Robinson was consistently
attracted to hopeful young
african-americans who were heavily
involved in the political process and
there stood by civil rights more than
anything else and I think I do believe
that he would stand with Obama but I
think he would be tempted by Romney's
campaign you mentioned the civil rights
connection in the early 70s he was very
complimentary of the Reverend Jesse
Jackson who by that time was kind of a
protege of Martin to King and maybe some
people thought the heir to King he he
said of Reverend Jackson who was running
an operation breadbasket program of
Chicago described him as a tall young
brave black Moses who can take us some
giant steps along the way to that
promised land of which dr. King spoke
that he would have support
Jesse Jackson's campaigns I do yeah he
was a big supporter of Jax and he worked
with him on operation breadbasket and
then he accepted one in the first vice
presidencies of Bush and so he was a big
supporter of it subjects now I don't
think it would hesitate to support him
at all Robinson also supported Charles
Rangel in his 1970 race against Adam
Clayton Powell jr. and so he was always
doing enthusiastic about young
african-american leaders who steered
progressively I'm not sure people
realize how active Robinson was in
trying to hold those in power
accountable um regardless of where they
resided I was struck by one letter to a
General Motors vice president that you
include in the book in which Robinson
virtually threatened the black boycott
because of an article that appeared in
The Wall Street Journal with some GM
plant manager making some racist
comments and Robinson wrote that you
know this is unacceptable
right a GM plant manager in Atlanta said
we're going to abide by local customs
and that meant that we're not going to
give decent jobs to African Americans in
this plant
Robinson reads the article in The Wall
Street Journal he fires off a letter to
my General Motors threatening the
boycott and then he sends the the letter
to labor leaders as well including water
Luthor so telling Luthor that Age
Meyerson and this may be in the works he
doesn't follow through with it but he
wouldn't hesitated he wouldn't pull his
punches when dealing with political
leaders or business leaders or civic
leaders you really wouldn't Malcolm X
later says that he's subservient to his
white bosses alright there's a lot of
evidence to the contrary an avid golfer
he even protested discrimination on the
golf courses there's a letter to the
then governor of Connecticut Abraham
Ribicoff when Robinson notes that a
friend of his apply for state handicap
and couldn't get one because he was
black and
and he writes that prejudice has no
place in any activity in America can you
imagine the day's athletes protesting
exclusionary practices on golf courses
you never see that from the Michael
Jordan's or even retired athletes no
it's sad in fact that's why I'm black
for his class citizenship is really out
there to give a better role model and
Robinson was in an avid golfer he loved
being on the golf course and nothing
really angered him more when he was on
the golf course when thinking about his
fellow African Americans being excluded
from courses Robinson himself was
excluded from country clubs in
Connecticut and I think that hurt him
deeply and he did all he could to
desegregate golf and he did a pretty
good decent job we're going to take a
short break for a couple of minutes
we're here talking with Michael long
author first-class citizenship civil
rights letters of Jackie Robinson we'll
be back in a moment more with Michael
long and Kevin Meredith in a moment
Monday on book TV hidden text of ancient
Greeks revealed by modern technology
book TV talks with William no curator of
manuscripts and rare books for the
Archimedes codex C cutting-edge
techniques for examining historic texts
and learn about the lost theories of the
mathematician who discovered the value
of pi' the Archimedes codex Monday 6
a.m. Eastern book TV on c-span -
afterwards with michael long and kevin
merida continues we're back here with
michael long
author of first-class citizenship the
civil rights letters of Jackie Robinson
we've been having a great conversation
we were talking during the break about a
letter that Barry Goldwater had written
that you wanted to mention well in 1961
go to water until Atlanta and he made a
famous speech what's now infamous
in which he said a republican party's
not going to get the african-american
vote and so in 64 and 68 we really ought
to go hunting where the Ducks are
Robinson hears this he reads about in
any boils over he sends a letter to
Nixon saying this is going to stay
Republican policy until somebody like
you who stands up and changes it Nixon
gets the letter he doesn't oblige at all
and yet in 1962 Robinson campaign for me
went out to California and campaigned
for him and the gubernatorial race Nixon
of course loses he gives his famous
pouting speech at the end of the
campaign the curse region that's right
oh yeah and Robinson says then he writes
a letter to Nixon and he says dick
because I think dick you are good for
politics good for America stand up and
soldier on
an amazing thing I'm always amazed at
Robinson to relentlessness and so even
when Terron Nixon and other politicians
didn't really oblige Nixon or Robinson
was still pretty faithful to the people
he liked speaking of faithfulness he was
a very faithful to the n-double-a-cp and
very active and you know making a number
of public appearances and helping raise
money and recruiting other athletes and
celebrities to attend events tell us
about that relationship in 1957 the year
he leads baseball Robinson I chaired the
fight for freedom campaign the
n-double-a-cp campaign that's designed
to raise a million dollars a year until
about 1963 to celebrate the Emancipation
Proclamation and to really increase the
membership rolls and Robinson's really
enthusiastic about it he chairs the
campaign he does a great job eventually
they raise money and though they the
membership rules actually slide a little
bit in 57 they pick up later and Rumson
just was a great time with the
n-double-a-cp
he also invokes Martin Luther King jr.
and fellow athletes and celebrities to
help raise money and so he went to
Jackson Mississippi for example to help
out Medgar Evers and raise lots of money
down there and eventually he sours on
the n-double-a-cp
and by 1967 he rights rather he writes
an open column in which he criticizes
the n-double-a-cp for being too oriented
towards the status quo and he believes
that Roy Wilkins is not exactly somebody
who allows dissent within the
n-double-a-cp
and he Wilkins and Robinson on a fiery
exchange of letters in 1967 and there
was some bad blood there but by the end
of his life our Robinson and Wilkins
were doing just fine and Wilkins had
actually cut off relationships between
the n-double-a-cp and the National Black
invention in 1972 because the NBC was
making some statements that seemed to go
against integration and Robinson looks
at that and the Irate smokings a
beautiful letter saying stay the course
I'm with you on this and I'm proud of
you're our leader National black
political convention which was held in
Gary Indiana in 1972 and it brought
activists and elected officials among
the things that they discuss Richard
Hatcher was one of the was the mayor
then was the host of it they discussed
whether or not they form an independent
black political party right you
mentioned about Robinson and Wilkins and
and I noted made a note of what Robinson
had called Wilkins he called his
leadership a kind of dictatorship and
unresponsive to the needs and aims of
the Negro masses which as you point out
Wilkins didn't take very well and
Robinson just replied I'm sorry you
cannot accept honest criticisms so he
was unafraid to stand by didn't seem to
be someone who was trying to soothe
feelings or worried about crushing
people spirits were there right no not
at all he was not mr. diplomacy he he
was aggress no no no no he was more
aggressive beyond the baseball diamond
than he was on the baseball diamond and
bananas of beige leather and well he's
so humble a very exact in the late 1960s
he actually says I think I've become
much more aggressive since I left
baseball and that's amazing when we
think that in 1955 Robinson stole home
played in the World Series I want to
return there to the u n-- double AC P
and SEL see the Southern Christian
Leadership Conference headed by King
there was some conflict between SCLC and
the n-double a-c-p islet and braid and
Robinson and Rachel Robinson were
influential influential social hosts and
they played role of liaison and they
would have afternoons of jazz at their
Connecticut home in which they would
invite lots of people to come and raise
money for very civil rights
and at one point they have an afternoon
of jazz to raise money for SCLC and the
n-double-a-cp and well I think Robinson
sometimes gets disappointed with the
n-double-a-cp and sees it as in status
quo I think it's also important to
remember that he really wanted to bring
these different these diverse civil
rights movements together and to focus
on one goal early I'm trying to remember
what year was it might have been 1960 he
actually takes the king to task for SCLC
members who criticize you n-double-a-cp
later he criticizes the n-double a-c-p -
you're right about that but he never
gives up hope
yeah the tension you refer to a lot of
it had to do with the fundraising am i
right the fundraising for civil rights
causes and who how the money was going
to be allocated who was going to get the
money in some respects SCLC is competing
for some of the same money that the
n-double-a-cp is right and Robinson
raised money for the n-double-a-cp
and the SPLC and for Corps Congress of
racial equality
he loved young folks he really did and
it gave a lot of his time and energy to
young folks who were involved in the
civil rights movement he was captivated
by the Freedom Riders and by course of
work in the south and so he did all I
could to back that as well and as we've
mentioned so far in the program he was
never predictable and even criticized
King admired him so much as a civil
rights leader but then when King called
for and then to the bombing in Vietnam
and and supported muhammad ali's right
you know refusing the draft Robinson
took him to test right yes
Robinson never caught Muhammad Ali
Muhammad Ali it was always Cassius Clay
with Robinson let me back up a little
bit and talk about King and Robinson
they were really heroes to each other
and from 1957 on
they work together Robinson avoids King
to take part in n-double-a-cp activities
King does marginally and King invites
Robinson to take part in SEL SCLC
activities Robinson goes II Albany
campaign he goes to the Birmingham km
campaign because SCLC rallies and raises
money for SCLC and during the Albany
campaign actually chaired it a campaign
to raise money for three black churches
that were burned because of their voter
registration efforts these two guys were
heroes to each other but there were
significant differences between them
Robinson
unlike King and steered towards
democratic socialism was a true
red-blooded American capitalist Robinson
was also deeply disappointed by Kings
descent from the Vietnam War in April
1967 King gave a famous anti-war speech
at Riverside Church in New York City and
following that Robinson wrote an open
letter in his newspaper column
criticizing King for descending from the
Vietnam and we have to remember that
ritual Robinson and Jackie Robinson had
a son Jackie jr. who was serving in
Vietnam and so they felt that Pole but
Robinson also wanted to give it LBJ a
pass on Vietnam and so he says the King
but why are you so hard on America and
you're not hard at all on the Communists
in Vietnam and yes I hear what you're
saying about calling for the Foreign
ended bombing but if we do that we'll
just give the Vietcong time to regroup
so that they can kill more of our sons
and he says why are you supporting
Cassius Clay in my mind Cassius Clay has
forfeited his citizenship here in
America and so he and King divided over
the Vietnam War after this King doesn't
write a letter he doesn't write a column
about Jackie Robinson he picks up the
phone he calls Robinson they have a long
discussion late at night
Robinson is absolutely delighted to get
the call and later he writes that King
so he disagrees with him is still one of
best guys in the world that that he
shares these uh letters with Rachel I
mean at the time and are these letters
or anything letters new to her
yes some of them are new to her I
believe read and talk and detail about
all of the letters but she has images of
her husband writing letters and I think
she feels that Jackie was much more
comfortable sometimes sitting down and
writing his thoughts out on paper than
he was maybe and picking up the phone
bill Robinson did that as well
Robinson remarkably was a great letter
writer and in one of his letters he says
that rachel is not but he is and then do
that and he that's right
he wrote hundreds and hundreds of
letters and first-class since how many
did you look at hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds and these were the major
letters two major political figures he
would write to people we just don't know
he would write a little kid who wrote
him fan letters he would write to a dog
who disagreed with his politics he would
write to virtually everybody who wrote
him and he would take amazing amounts of
time to write letters and that's like
lost art in our society now absolutely
yeah don't write letters you never see
this back and forth correspondence with
such major figures many of them very
busy figures now we have email and
delete right yes I can't imagine
Robinson being attracted to email
although maybe he would fire off a
blistering email that would be quickened
to the point that's right but he loved
to explain his thoughts and these
letters really show that he would take
great care in explaining his thoughts on
a policy or vision or personality he
thought that there was a right way and a
wrong way to support the cause of black
advancement as we see in some of the
letters that he wrote
hence those he thought were black
militants you know he said some very
harsh things about Adam Clayton Powell
jr. who is a very charismatic
you know flamboyant congressman from
Harlem and they got into a kind of a row
he was troubled by piles call for blacks
to boycott n-double-a-cp because it was
an organization in piles view that there
were too many whites involved in the
leadership to meet whites as benefactors
and Pao also was a big support of the
black Muslims tell us about that
relationship the relationship between
Robinson and Powell is a bit complicated
but in the particular event that here
you just referenced Robinson is upset
that Howe had called for a boycott of
the n-double a-c-p and some other
organizations in which African Americans
aren't in full control in leadership
positions and Robinson wrote an open
letter in the New York Amsterdam news
1963 criticizing Powell's stance and
defending the n-double-a-cp has achieved
civil rights organization of the United
States and the DD was right about that
he goes on to defend white leaders spin
guards and others who supported the
n-double a-c-p quite a bit and he says
that they've done a lot more for the
movement than you have you've really
heard the movement in many ways Robinson
is an integrationist and the deepest
recesses of his heart and so when
militants like Adam Clayton Powell jr.
Edie what I hope we talk later about
Malcolm and get right about when they
make a case for separatism he really
flies off the handle you know I was
struck by some of the the language I
mean he says about in in this letter
about to POW I can only conclude Adam
that this latest tantrum of yours see
stems from the fact that you're
infuriated because Roy Wilkins and the
board of the n-double a-c-p did not
rush to your defense in your recent
battle with your fellow congressman you
set up the usual crybaby yell that you
were being persecuted because you are a
black man when it was pretty obvious
that you had placed yourself in a
vulnerable position to be condemned by
many people with many different motives
the Negro people are growing up Adam and
I did not believe they are sympathetic
any longer to the business of supporting
anything anyone does wrong or right
simply because he belongs to the race
that's a pretty pointed this is the
United States congressman and probably
one of the more prominent ones which
gives to your point of Robinson at the
end of the day was always integrationist
yeah that's his personality coming
through right there and I do want to add
though that Robinson came to pals
defense when the house sought to prevent
Powell from taking exceeded Gerald Ford
was relating to the effort at the time
and Robinson came to his defense and
said this is just part of the white
backlash and it's going to hurt the
Republican efforts to gain the
african-american vote and it really
stands next Adam Clayton Powell is
incredible it's admirable because here's
the guy Adam Clayton Powell with whom
Robinson sharply disagrees then yet when
the house seeks to exclude him he goes
right to Palace side and standing right
next to him I'm 19
what does that reflect you thinking in
Robinson well I think it reflected where
his priorities were and where his
ultimate loyalties were as well
Robinson was deeply disturbed at a
growing weight backlash in the civil
rights movement and he would come to the
defense of not only Adam Clayton Powell
but later the Black Panthers and we can
really see him lining up his loyalties
at that point let's get to Malcolm X
because those were I thought some of the
most pointed exchanges in you know
Malcolm X of course is a very eloquent
speaker but Robinson they there was like
a battle in the center of the Ring those
two going back and forth through letters
yeah here's what happened around Bunch
mid-speech in the cells in which he said
that powell and malcolm wrong guilty of
perpetrating a black form of the racist
virus Robinson wrote a column defending
bunch from attacks launched by pal and
Malcolm in response to that speech and
after that column Malcolm X sat down and
wrote and wrote OH
a fiery letter to Robinson and he says
you're subservient to your white bosses
you've been subservience to them since
Branch Rickey you've done it with Branch
Rickey you're done it with a way of
black and now you're doing it with
Nelson Rockefeller
you're more faithful to your white
benefactors than you are to the black
masses you're out of touch with black
masses you were cunning on the baseball
diamond he says but I think you're even
more cunning now and you're misleading
your people and Robinson fires back his
own letter he says Malcolm coming from
you and attack as a tribute this is
exactly exactly
Malcolm or the separatists Robinson was
an integrationist Malcolm called for the
use of any means necessary
Robinson favored a nonviolent approach
in the civil rights movement malcolm
favored a temporary black stain a black
stain and Robinson stood against that
Robinson and Bunch and King believed as
they separated themselves from pow and
Malcolm that they had a stake in America
that they had a deep stake in America
and that their children would one day be
able to cash in on this stake in America
and Malcolm is nowhere near that
position and they just clash there was
an edge to that here's one thing in a
dig that Robinson gave Malcolm X he says
Malcolm is very militant on Harlem
Street corners where militancy is not
dangerous yeah don't you love that
earlier Robinson was criticized for not
taking his message to Harlem and so
there were people who wrote to the New
York Amsterdam news saying come to
Harlem square Jackie and speak to us
there and we'll see how you're treated
there later he turns the tables and he
says that Malcolm is Milton only a
hard-on that you just said and indeed
there was some truth to that I think and
that's quite a dig and although Malcolm
writes and one of his responses to
Robinson and you Negro leaders whose
bread-and-butter depend on your ability
to make your white boss think you have
all these Negroes under control quote
unquote better be thankful that I wasn't
in Mississippi after Medgar Evers was
murdered nor in Birmingham after the
murder of those four innocent little
Negro girls and by which he was saying
if I had been there there wouldn't have
been any marches or rode that thing at
one point he said that the the only
funerals that he would go to would be of
white Mississippians not not to the
megger ever funeral which was one of the
ones that Robinson criticized for not
attending right or Robinson's own hero
ran away eventually stabbed him in the
back yes let me add this as well Malcolm
the welcome end Jackie Robinson clashed
quite a bit I think that Robinson grew
closer to Malcolm's position at the end
of his life I really do I think that
Robinson well he never became a
separatist I became more aware of his
blackness than he ever did and in 1972
he is saying I can't stand for the
national anthem I can't sing the
national anthem I know that I'm a black
man in a white world and to me that
sounds a lot like Malcolm and I think he
grew a little bit closer to Malcolm's
position and Malcolm grew a little bit
closer to Robinson's position as well
especially after he left the black
Muslims
especially then up going back to earlier
in common Robinson calls Malcolm
basically a coward he doesn't think that
Malcolm will ever stand up and fight he
doesn't think that Malcolm will ever use
a gun in some ways you just think said
Malcolm is a coward and that he stands
behind Elijah Muhammad and used that as
a as a nice or better uses Elijah
Muhammad as a nice cloak and then and
just basically disappears he doesn't
think that Malcolm will ever stand up
and fight for his rights and he points
to a case in California when black
Muslims relied on the courts to settle a
dispute and didn't do anything there
they're not going to do anything now of
course Malcolm ultimately stood up with
his life because he was gunned down in
the Audubon Ballroom in Harlem in 1965
and you know widely uh you know been
reported and suggested that Muslims
maybe with black Muslims with with
infiltrated FBI informants had something
to do with it he ended up Malcolm X
split with the Nation of Islam and with
Elijah Muhammad and went did his
pilgrimage and he had came to a broader
understanding realization of what Islam
was so he evolved himself early and he
was wildly he was widely eulogized
by lots of people but not by Jackie
Robinson which is really interesting I
wish he had but he didn't eulogize
Malcolm after his assassination and to
me it's still a bit disappointing
Michael till of viewers a little about
yourself I'm a an associate professor of
religious studies and Peace and Conflict
Studies at Elizabethtown College in
Pennsylvania I teach courses in a
religion and politics I'm married to a
lovely spouse corn we have two lively
children Jackson who's nine and mate is
two and I love this book especially
because it's really the first one that
Jackson became interested in
and I think that's probably like my
favorite project so far
and did they kid read some of the
letters and not yet bring him to it
that's why I let him grow into it I
showed him the place in the book where
his name appears and he read a little
bit of that but he's excited about
learning about Jackie Robinson and
nothing could excite me more than
knowing that my own son is learning
about Jackie Robinson civil rights
legacy do you have a favorite letter I
have lots of favorite letters I really
do I'm going to read one will you sure
yeah in fact a long time ago when I was
working on this I wrote some favorites
down in the front of the book and if
I'll switch glasses here I think I'll be
able to read some of them this is a
letter if you don't mind I'll read out
in one form King to Robinson and I love
this especially because it's following
my comments about Jackson my son Jackson
my dear Jackie your address at our SCLC
banquet made it one of the highlights of
our convention I don't know what we
would have done through these past years
without your ardent support and interest
we certainly count you among our most
valuable friends and it pleases me to
say that you have continued to give the
kind of leadership throughout your
career that we are proud to be
identified with this is certainly an
important contribution to mankind as a
whole and especially to Negro of people
who too often this is my favorite part
must see their heroes of their youth
tarnished by selfish compromises and
mediocre judgment may God continue to
enable you to maintain the high level of
leadership and integrity which has been
yours throughout your career Sincerely
Yours Martin Luther King jr. I just love
that letter because it's so true
Robinson maintained his integrity on
those Facebook post Baseball years and
in still my hero you have another you
like to raise the to let me go to a
letter that Robinson Road to
pitches 1972 biography and I'll read
just a little excerpt from this letter
to Michael hammelburg in California as a
hammelburg agency by the way it's still
up and running in California doing well
dear mr. Hamill Berg but baseball is
still quite them perfect as I shall
prove and the chapter there are no more
mr. Ricky's I love baseball and even
though I do in fact because I do I will
continue to criticize it I love this
country it has done a lot for me and
this country I grandson of a slave son
of a sharecropper rose to the Hall of
Fame as I say this country has done a
lot for me and I've done in return the
best that has let me do for it and that
is why I do not have to wave flags or
have stickers on my car or their
patriotic cufflinks or armbands on my
sleeve
I do not have to leave this country at
the suggestion of some third-generation
European who wants to compare
grandfathers his who came here seeking
freedom and immediately enslaved others
for his own advancement